The raccoon man from that one movie printed on
it Chewbacca oh Rick they want you to say Wubba
lubba dub dub at the end screw that we're not
Welcome back everyone pour one out for the Choco
Taco this will be my full Rick and Morty season
6 episode 4 video there were a whole bunch of
Easter eggs and references so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel I'm doing
videos for all the episodes be sure to subscribe
to get them careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet we'll just start
at the beginning and work our way through the
shop by shot talking about Easter eggs and WTF
moments as we go along starting with the episode
title Knight family which is just a reference
to the unconscious versions of themselves that
took over because of the Sun ambulator that did
things that they didn't want to do but the whole
joke here is that it's the same people like it's
the same family it's just their unconscious minds
who are in control when they're in that state
so like everything that they do in that state
are things that the regular versions wanted to do
subconsciously but just never actually did Jerry's
the clue for this because the night version
of Jerry is almost the exact same as the day
version like there's no difference there equally
as claim the summer night person makes it seem
like there may have been some other secret villain
controlling Summer's body but the joke here is
that deep down inside summer really does want to
take over the planet eventually and take over the
family in general so hat tip to keep an eye on
her in the future like Rick is probably going
to keep a closer watch on her in the future but
there have been previous episodes where they've
shown her being like this where she really enjoys
being the ruler of a people but the real joke
here is the joke about Rick not wanting to do the
dishes like night Summers the first one that snaps
because the dishes are so bad and she just wants
Rick to help out a little bit and the rest of the
episode is basically showing how far he will go
to avoid doing the dishes even at the end of the
episode when the Knight family is willing to come
to a compromise Rick is unwilling to do so he'd
rather live like a slave than do the dishes the
episode has done is sort of like a horror episode
like it's a parody of horror movies like this the
actress Spencer Grandma who plays summer said that
it was her favorite episode because she loves
these kinds of horror movies and it was a big
summer episode one of the other big changes in
this episode is that they start with a special
little text title I don't think that they've ever
done this in Rick and Morty before is taken from
a real poem that T.S Eliot actually wrote like
even though it sounds kind of strange it is a
real poem it says when you're all alone in the
middle of the night and you wake in a sweat in
a hell of a fright when you're all alone in the
middle of the bed and you wake like someone hit
you on the head you've had a cream of a nightmare
dream and you've got the who has Jerry also makes
a who has reference later meaning that he
also read T.S Eliot like he's got a little
bit of culture in him the whole joke with best
sheet counting app is that normally you would
have somebody do that in their head like just
count sheep and you would do it silently while
you were trying to sleep they said that the whole
idea of the song nambulator the term somnambulate
literally means to sleep walk and that's kind of
what the Knight family does in the episode they're
like the sleepwalking version of the family Rick
and Morty use it to get crazy ABS Beth learns it
to play the trumpet summer learned Spanish in
the whole bit with Jerry just being super lame
only using it to be his own pen pal but I think
what they're trying to say here is that Jerry is
his own best friend which also does work in their
favor later because Knight Jerry winds up helping
them pretty much throughout the entire episode
they use all kinds of horror movie tropes like
the way that they light the episode the way it
takes place mostly in the night they use a bunch
of jump scares like horror movies they use all
the creepy music you hear in horror movies even
the end of the episode is done is sort of like
a parody of horror movie endings like a very
Downer dystopian type of ending Rick specifically
calls the night people their unconscious self but
the way I thought about it is that basically like
everything that the night people wanted were the
subconscious desires of the waking family so like
everything that the Knight family does are things
that the regular family wanted to do but never
actually did he's got a new word for plebs calling
them zebs like somehow that's meant to be worse
than being a plebe the whole joke with Summer's
work around here to get him to let them use it
it's just more her taking advantage of his need to
always have the coolest thing and be the center of
attention they mentioned Postmates I wonder if it
was meant to be an integration like did Postmates
actually pay them money because it seemed like a
weird reference to make sometimes Brands will
do that but like for instance they make a lot
of Marvel jokes Marvel does not pay them money
to make fun of Marvel they said it the whole bit
with the calendar because there are a couple big
time jumps in the episode like it's been almost
a couple weeks that they've been using it the
first time then later a bunch more time goes by
then at the end of the episode there's another big
time Jump which they pay off with the Choco Tacos
which is somehow like the worst possible thing
that could have happened to them like that's
the thing that they're all pissed off about how
could they get rid of Choco Tacos that's as you
take it from real life like in real life they
stop selling Choco Tacos when Morty comes in to
show them his abs they play it for a big joke like
he's getting ready to whip his junk out because he
says Ah look what I got here is he unzips the
bag but they don't show you the bag till they
zoom out like wait a minute what is he unzipping
here what's going on he and Rick started podcast
called fabsolutely fabulous which is just a
joke about all the ridiculous podcasts that
people start and then quit like they only have the
podcast for like a really short period before the
night family takes over and that's the end of the
podcast apparently it turns into a super big deal
though in the short time that they had it running
like they joke about having Nancy Pelosi is one
of the guests on it like that's how big their
podcast is is getting which they also pay off
later in the episode when they actually show you
them podcasting with a bunch of quick references
to each other and it's meant to be a joke about
the way the podcast hosts talk to each other on
podcasts they had them do that funny commercial
break because they're sponsored by the boxer
Lobster company which is a fake business he also
makes the Chewbacca Star Wars joke in the Wubba
lubba dub dub joke also joking about selling out
like the whole joke is that Rick and Morty do all
kinds of AD placements like there are all kinds
of assets they post on their YouTube channel so
in real life Rick and Morty sell out all the time
but Rick is always complaining in episodes about
how he doesn't want to sell out the under the
pillow address on Jerry's letters was a reference
to them leaving each other notes under the pillow
that's how Day Jerry asked Knight Jerry for help
later in the episode and it also turns out that
he's a huge Tori Amos fan Morty makes a Flapjacks
pancake reference to his abs he seems weirdly
obsessed with his body during this episode and
I think one of the other jokes here about day and
night Jerry being so lame is that they're the ones
that kind of set this off too like night Jerry
gives Day Jerry the note from from night summer
to kind of start everything like could you please
wash your dishes a little bit before you put them
in the sink and that starts Rick's whole war with
the night family like how dare they ask me to wash
the dishes I've refused to wash the dishes we get
to go back into Rick's room for I think the third
time on the series we haven't actually been in
here that many times he's got a very elaborate
rooster crow device that he's using as an alarm
clock that hatches and grows a rooster to maturity
where it gives off his rooster cry waking him up
then it destroys it cleaning the mess and repeats
it the next day so it's just a joke about all the
weird links that Rick will go to to do things that
he could normally do much easier if he made
some compromises like the whole episode is a
joke about how Rick never wants to compromise
because like his rooster device here actually
has a digital alarm clock on it and already kind
of makes a sound like he doesn't actually need
it to create a rooster to do what he wants it to
do zoom and enhance all over his walls he's got a
bunch of Easter eggs and references for previous
Seasons there's a picture of aberdolph linkler
this is a zigerian from the M Night episode this
is Dr Xenon Bloom from the anatomy Park episode
there's a me seeks there's plans for his original
spaceship made from common household items over on
the left here this seems kind of like one of the
Cronenberg people from Cronenberg World he's also
got schematics for his classic laser gun that
we saw in me seeks and destroy their schematics
for a me seeks box and there's plans for a couple
other devices in a fuel cell you also notice that
he's got a giant box of old school floppy discs on
the ground like the old school 3x5 discs that you
would have had if you had PC back in the 90s or
early 2000s you also notice when he comes into the
kitchen and notices there are no dishes it gets
pissed off he uses the word [__] because he just
used one in his alarm clock they have that whole
joke with a side quest in the forbidden zone which
I think is meant to be a parody of the 80s sci-fi
movie adventures in the forbidden zone They also
use it to make a Marmaduke joke Marmaduke is a
cartoon character and it's meant to be a parody of
a bunch of different things like a giant Avengers
Infinity War type of scene where Thor goes to make
Stormbreaker on the Dwarven Homeworld and Rick
goes to make a version of dinner plates that can't
be destroyed like the vibranium or adamantium
version of plates they even have an over-the-top
joke about how their 110 percent indestructible
and even bother to stamp it into the place
themselves there are a couple details like this
in the episode where it kind of makes me think
that it points the episode is taking place either
in a simulation or inside someone's head because
why would Rick stamp a plate 110 indestructible
if he's all about being accurate technically a
hundred percent would be the most indestructible
you could possibly get and like at the end of the
episode with a car chase they have the Adderall
truck the over-the-top car crash with the gasoline
Factory the dynamite Factory the dry Leaf storage
facility and when they're finally driving away
like they've escaped and they're trying to
make it to the airport the road sign just
says an airport like it's super vague and that's
usually something you would see if it were a dream
or if it were happening in some fake reality you
could always theorize that this episode featured
a family that wasn't like the main family there
have been theories like that in the past like just
based on the way that they look or the things that
they do like oh this could be about an alternate
version of the family from a different reality or
it could just be that the events of the episode
didn't actually happen and that's why some of the
references were so vague like what's the backstory
with Rick and this other guy making him the dinner
plates that are indestructible like they had this
whole backstory he claims that he owes him his
life what is that story they'll probably never
pay that off either then they go full horror genre
again when he wakes up in the Knight family is
attacking him while he's strapped down forcing
him to eat the leftover food because the whole
episode is a joke about how far people will go to
avoid doing the dishes if you live in a house with
like really young kids that refuse to do dishes
you could probably show them this scene and it
might scare them into actually doing the dishes
even though the plot of the episode some of the
moments are kind of ridiculous the animation like
the way that they parroted everything is actually
on point then they said it the whole bit with
night summer being the one to rule over the family
what might be happening here because normally you
would expect any version of Rick to try and be the
dominant one is that because the Knight family is
like the unconscious subconscious version of the
Dave family maybe subconsciously Rick really does
want to give up control and just be part of the
family and have fun with the rest of them so when
that part of of him takes over he's more like that
he's more submissive and like I said the joke was
summer being that she really does secretly want to
take over the world and that just kind of comes to
the surface during the night version of her when
summer makes the Terry Gilliam reference talking
about the sleep deprivation suit that rig makes
for her specifically it's a Time Bandits reference
in that movie the characters all wear like really
similarly weird looking outfits also love the joke
about the Mountain Dew in the DayQuil that he says
that kids in southern Europe call do quill like
that sounds so crazy that it could actually be a
thing but if you do actually live in southern
Europe and you know people that actually do
that let me know in the comments you would be
surprised at the crazy stuff the kids will do
to try and have a good time also this might be a
bit of a Simpsons joke like they make a joke about
Mountain Dew being gross they did that on The
Simpsons it's one of my favorite Simpsons jokes
ever why do you have to watch that awful taste
out of my mouth Mountain Dew or crab juice and oh
I'll take a crab juice that scene is taken
from the New York City episode that was pulled
because this was taking place at the World Trade
Center they pulled the episode from syndication
after 9 11. then when summer reacts to the Knight
family they have this big horror movie Easter egg
with the way she reacts like the camera movement
zooming in on her here they actually use this on
The Simpsons too you could say The Simpsons did it
before but really in both cases they're meant to
be parodies of classic horror movies with reaction
shots they said it the whole joke with the Knight
family's grand plan to take over and rule the day
but secretly what they actually want to do is do
all the things that the regular family wanted to
do but never actually took the time to do which
is basically just go on vacations and have fun
together like that's their whole thing that's
all they want to do they just want to go out and
have a good time and this is where the episode
gets pretty real like pretty personal because most
people in real life do things this way like even
me I want to go on all these fun vacations but
how would I get any work done so I don't go on
vacations and it's the same lesson at the end
of the episode where like the night family runs
out of money because they spend all the time time
having fun and not doing any of the busy work the
boring stuff that the Day family normally does
they're meant to be all the regular versions
of the family's unconscious desires completely
freed like what will you do if there were no
limits if you could do anything you wanted to do
they referenced the Shoney's again and then they
pull the same old-timey reaction shot parody with
Rick when he's reacting to night summer revealing
herself and I think what's actually going on
here is what's happening later in the episode
like they have the joke during the car chase with
people bouncing back and forth between the night
and the day versions as they get knocked out and
then brought back to Consciousness I think what
happened here is the idea is that summer took
off the sleep deprivation device and because
she'd been so sleep divive she just passed out
immediately and we're just watching it happen
before our eyes and that's why night summer is
able to take over so quickly like later in the
episode you see one of the family members get
knocked out and immediately the night version
takes over until they get woken up and also when
night summer says to Rick your opinion means very
little to me that's something that Rick has
repeated to summer in previous Seasons many
times sorry summer Europe means very little
to me sorry Rick but your opinion means very
little to me I'm not sure what all the robot
appliances are meant to be parodies of outside
of the Transformers or cylons some of you think
that this guy looks kind of like the robot from
the black hole movie The Other next time Jump
and it's been a little bit over a month since
the last one at least at this point the whole joke
is that they're just torturing the Day family like
they're just making them do all this menial labor
like would you be doing cooler stuff there's all
this advanced technology why does everything
seem so old-timey in this living room the joke
about the movies is they're making Beth burn all
the movies with the word day in the title like
Independence Day Groundhog Day Ferris Bueller's
Day Off and that's why she saves the Talladega
Nights movie because it has night in the title
this is where the episode starts to get really
ridiculous like really over the top so you start
to wonder like wait a minute is this actually
really happening or somebody just imagining this
they bring Gene back the clown on him a couple
times he's kind of like the family's punching
bag pretty much every episode he's in something
terrible winds up happening to him when the
car chase is happening you notice they pass
a you tow truck on the highway but the mascot is
literally a talking toe the bit with her falling
into the empty boxes is also a Trope in a lot
of series like it's been used so many times
The Simpsons have done it a bunch of times the
weird joke about the cops shooting everyone up
I think is meant to be like a Cod on bad cops in
real life for the past few years but it did feel
kind of weird the way they put in the episode and
just the whole car chase in general is meant to
be a parody of horror movie car chases I did think
it was funny the way that they highlighted Jerry's
Kink here like he gets hard while she's choking
him and even night Beth gets a little disgusted
with him like uh the shot of Rick jumping between
cars with the shotgun also feels like a direct
movie parody like this is meant to be a direct
scene taken from some other movie but I'm not
sure which one it is so if you think you know
write it below in the comments and then they pay
off the bit about Rick doing anything literally
anything going to any length to avoid doing the
dishes even submitting to the Knight family like
I said the dystopian ending of the episode with a
special credits is also a parody of horror movies
that have similar Downer endings like this but
the actual credits are real credits like this is
all the production staff that actually worked on
the episode in all the scenes are just the Knight
family doing all the things that unconsciously the
waking family wanted to do but never took the time
to do like they go to Bed Bath and Beyond they go
to what seems like Hawaii on vacation they watch
The Night at the Museum movie together they took
a vacation to Japan it seems like they went to
Paris night Beth became a virtuoso trombone player
and the whole joke with a mug is that it's just
the family showing genuine admiration for each
other like a loving family would in a way that
you would expect a regular family would have a
really really hard time doing like Rick would
never do something like that unless something
really went wrong he actually does care about the
family they joke about it at the end of episode
one this season but he just refuses to admit it
in the actual post-credits scene they pay off the
joke with everything getting repossessed because
they spent all the family's money they did all
the things the regular family wanted to do but
didn't because they had to spend all their time
earning money having jobs doing the stuff that you
would normally have to do to just have a life love
night Rick's solution like he pulls the gun out
as if he's trying to tell them that oh I have a
a solution here we'll just all shoot ourselves
and that'll fix everything but actually just
destroying this on the emulator paying off the
time Jump joke with the Choco Tacos like of all
the possible things that could have happened them
spending all the family's money them destroying
the house them losing Choco Tacos is somehow way
worse so everyone pour one out for Choco Tacos I'm
sure at some point in the future they'll bring a
version of those back I'm talking about in real
life but maybe in Rick and Morty like in a future
episode of future season when they bring them back
maybe Rick will talk about Choco Tacos if you
spotted any other Easter eggs and references in
the episode that I didn't talk about in the
video just write them Below in the comments
in my full episode 5 video we'll post next week
after they release it everyone click here for my
Full House of the Dragon episode 7 video and
click here for all my Rick and Morty episode
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one